America Isaac nation is founded on
ideals that are Universal
and are built one of their largest
African economy a lot of military
however I think that the people those
who have lived under prosperity for a
long time and that's one of the main
contradictions is that they start
turning against ideas that made them
prosperous at the moment and uh so so
one of us say the ideals of ideas Beyond
borders is making sure that the American
ideals spread that they can continue
kind of like when you send the humans to
Mars so in that way Humanity can
continue right is that send the American
ideals all over the world so in that way
these these ideals will continue
thank you
I'm Dave Rubin and we are on location
here at the local studios in Miami and I
am joined by the founder of ideas Beyond
borders but more importantly a brand new
American and my old friend Faisal Saeed
amutar it is good to see you my man
thank you so much for having me again
that's it's been a journey Faisal we
were just discussing you well first off
you've been on this show we you know
there's the Jordan Peterson like 15
times there's the Gad said probably 14
times the Douglas Murray probably about
14 times you're close I'm close you're a
top Fiverr for sure let's make a 72 so
that's right
it is um
every time I sit down with you it's just
an absolute Joy because you you come
from a place in the world you come from
Iraq uh well you know what give
everybody the one minute recap on your
on your like can you do it in a minute
the life story because then we'll get
into all the other stuff but I think it
sets up such a beautiful story that
you're now what'd you say one year
American uh 2019. it's been four years
we're a citizen for four years yeah
um but then I've been treating you like
a brand new citizen give it that way
yeah introduce me next time to the best
barbecue in town
um give it give everybody like the one
minute story yeah that gets you to
America um so I was born in Babylon in
Iraq south of Baghdad then Andrea Saddam
Hussein so I lived first in those
dominosan and then after the war
Al-Qaeda took over my neighborhood uh I
decided to be outspoken against those
crazies at the time and then I ended up
on a death list also losing main members
of my family I left to Lebanon Lebanon
to Malaysia Malaysia to eventually
accept the United States as a refugee in
2013.
um and for me like the reason why when I
moved here and and seeing like people uh
no I thought for at the beginning that
people like people would appreciate the
value is that I used to fight for when I
was in Iraq
um and now 10 years later I think is
that I was wrong
um which is a condemnation of your new
country it's not it's not a combination
of of the country I would say and that
that's that's again the the journey is
that I've had an amazing pleasant
experience in America
um I'm so grateful to be here and in
fact the word Grateful is even an
understatement uh a year after I moved
in I was hosted by an American family
for a year in Northern Virginia in which
they treated me as their as their kid uh
the amount of support from people like
you and friends and others who like
elevated my voice and and made me part
of like the scene
um I don't think this I if I immigrate
to another country I would not have that
experience so I'm amazingly grateful and
that's what I think is the kind of the
the contradiction is that there's my
experience and I know it's experience of
many thousands and not ten thousands of
immigrants
um and then there is those like kind of
champagne socialists in in Williamsburg
and other places who will be like oh
this country sucks and I cannot get my
life started at 2PM and and uh and not
only that is that this country is they
try to speak on behalf of those who
um who whose claim that they are the
victims and uh and that pisses me off uh
to say to say say the least yes so one
of one of the things that I've been like
kind of thinking about is that uh how
like the the the the people here we need
to figure out a way to make them realize
what they are taking for granted and I
think is that it's not just my voice
that matters but I think I've been in
meeting with your show you I've
interviewed a lot of people you have
interviewed yummy Park you interviewed a
lot of the voices that are gaps
immediately the same message because the
thing is like we don't even have to
speak it is just true
so that's that's sometimes I try not to
speak so much because I was like just
like it's self-evident yeah that's
that's written in the U.S Constitution
or Declaration of advanced I guess
you are an American studied for the test
I got it look the first time we met was
the day that you did my show for the
first time right at the beginning yes so
this was uh I think October of 2015 if
I'm not mistaken and Melissa Chen our
mutual friend introduced us and she said
you know you should just have this guy
on the show and just talk to him and I
was like all right let's see what
happens and and here I met this guy who
was roughly new to America but I was
like he loves Freedom you want to talk
about Classical liberalism and ideas
which now you've turned into this
non-profit and all of this stuff so you
you just freaking love this country I
mean it's just it just comes through
very clearly with you yeah and and the
thing is like I love this country even
before I came here even though my
experience with America is is
mixed back I mean my first introduction
to America was a Humvee in front of our
house uh with with U.S soldiers what
year was that that's what 2003 when when
the because I was born at the first war
like the uh so I guess my parents were
busy when there was no electricity and I
was I had sex and I was born but
1990 and then 91 is when I was born yeah
uh and then the the second one is 2003
and I remember that day very vividly is
that we were watching the local
television and there was also Iranian
television was intercepting in Iraq and
they were telling us that the US
military is being defeated in the South
and they're all these soldiers being
killed and the Iraqis are winning and
stuff like that and then my my brother
was in in the second floor and he's like
there are American tanks in front of our
house
and then within like half an hour like
the American tanks were bombing my
elementary school which wasn't which as
a military base of the Iraqi Army and
within like a couple days that was in
early April
um pretty much all of the highway which
our house was in front of the highway
where the U.S military came into Baghdad
and that was my first introduction to
the Americans uh so so what did you
think of America then
um honestly this was more like an alien
feeling I'm like who are these people
and then then I mean thank goodness I
mean we were my parents studied in the
UK so so I was able to speak English
even though I still my English is still
depends on how much Margaritas I've had
during the day but I was gonna get to
Margaritas later because the true way
that I know you're an American you love
a margarita more than anyone I know and
that was yeah thanks to Texas
technically Mexican but well well it's a
Melting Pot
and so yeah that so the the first I
would say the first interaction with the
American was American Soldier and they
were like very friendly they were kind
of very curious and they were like oh
here we are here to like defeat Saddam
Hussein however
things escalated badly very quickly so
so the reaction of of the American Army
to Iraqis became more negative as I
started getting more attacked uh however
one of the benefits that came in after
the war was the internet
and I was I mean 2003 2004 the internet
was not as advanced as this today
um and but I was able to like just
explore the world through so internet
and see what America is like and what
what the values of America were so like
when all of that Civil Wars was
happening I was sitting at home reading
Thomas Jefferson in the in the Age of
Reason by Thomas Paine and Common Sense
and stuff like that and I was like these
are and and the story like of America at
least the beginning story and even like
the Europe 33 years war Etc or the
origin of the Enlightenment is what I
think is the Middle East is facing right
now so it's like it's the founding is of
America and the and the Civil Wars that
it had and the European Civil Wars when
persistent and Catholics stuff like is
what we what I witnessed so it's just
like we're 300 years behind right
um and my goal is to is to bring those
values into the region that I came from
which I think are the reason why
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people are prosperous
are the values that found in America
which I think our values were spreading
and you quite literally are doing that
with your life that's what ideas Beyond
borders does exactly and I think is that
even with my disappointment and I mean
in a theoretical world let's say if
America turns against America let's say
I think that these values are so worth
defending so I think is that spreading
the values of Freedom America is itself
an idea as well as a country and that's
I think what is very unique about this
country is that uh there is no I mean
not with all my love for my Canadian
neighbors but they don't there's no
Canadian idea that but America as a
nation is founded on ideals that are
Universal uh and are built one of their
largest freaking economy in a lot of
military however I think that the people
those who have lived under prosperity
for a long time and that's one of the
main contradictions is that they start
turning against ideas that made them
prosperous at the moment and uh so so
one of I would say the ideals of ideas
Beyond orders is making sure that the
American ideal surprise that they can
continue kind of like when you send the
humans to Mars so in that way Humanity
can continue right is that send the
American ideals all over the world so in
that way these these ideals will
continue does it blow your mind I mean
when you go back you were just
interacting not too long ago and you
traveled the world obviously when you go
to the places where it's not okay to say
what you think and all of these things
and you're translating books so that
people can read these great texts in the
countries that aren't as open uh and
then you compare that to the people here
it you know who are fighting against
Freedom or or you know not really aware
of how good it is must drive you nuts it
does I think is is because
um that's again one of the one of the
contradictions is that uh when you live
under freedom for a long time uh you
start becoming cynical I think one of
the main things that I dislike about
kind of a specific section of of
Americans not obviously not all I think
as I said I think most Americans are
apolitical and to some extent they don't
know what they have and they don't
necessarily
um appreciate what they have but
honestly if you're a man of the success
yeah
um and I think I'm more like those who
are cynical like I remember I gave a
speech at UC Berkeley and and there were
and and I was talking about like Mike's
first experience of a suicide bomber and
how literally the ecosystem that allows
this thing to happen and one of the
students was like oh we have the same
thing here I'm like where
I always see is like a shawarma
restaurant that's up I mean the
Shawarma is like I don't know made from
rabbit meat you're telling me a Berkeley
shawarma place isn't the best no I I
recommend that little places
um so so I was like okay seriously like
you how delusional you must think that
you think that life in America as bad as
it is in other places not not I mean
some places obviously are developed like
America Norway I just was in Norway it's
pretty cool country yeah uh but just say
it's also a very small largely
homogeneous exactly and and when they
had start having more immigrants even
even Denmark and other places they they
get confused right because they are very
homogeneous that's why even like systems
like Democratic socialism whatever is
called
um can operate because more like a tribe
that became a country but but the idea
in America is like you have all of these
people from different parts of the world
most of them able to coexist and
function I think it's pretty wonderful
um and because I come from a country and
place a region in which diversity is
actually a curse not a blessing so so
many people fight for a homogeneous
place the Kurds are fighting further on
place the Assyrians and the Christians
want their own small territory uh the
shias want their thing and so in a way
it's like where I come from diversity is
is a curse and while here
because the identity of the country is
built on ideals
um and unfortunately now there's a whole
identitarian identity politics World in
which everything is about is about race
and stuff but I think the founding of
America was about ideals and and we've
seen functioning for 300 years and I
think it's really worth preserving I
mean I'm definitely not giving up and
I'm trying my best now 10 years later uh
to be more involved in the locals
conversation even though the Middle East
is enough headache I mean I I've had my
fair share of tequila every couple days
and
um
It's never enough but but I think is
that I think as a duty of now being a a
citizen and being welcomed by this
wonderful country I think it's also part
of my duty to contribute here in any way
I can what's going on in Iraq now I feel
like we don't talk about Iraq nobody
knows what's going on you know people
look back in hindsight at the war in a
very uh mostly negative with very
different glasses than at the time you
actually in retrospect you're happy that
I don't want to put words in your mouth
but I think it essentially has happy
that the Americans liberated from Saddam
but that may not be connected to exactly
what's going on now
um yeah I mean I support
I I wouldn't say in a direct way like
that I support the war but I think is
that the options that are available I
mean I look at the Iraq and and from
kind of the lowest of standards and and
mostly because of its history Iraq
started with the King that the British
installed after the Ottoman Empire the
King was killed by the Communists and
then the Socialists killed the
Communists and then Saddam Hussein
killed a socialist and then Saddam
Hussein was hacked that's the history
so this is so when you're trying to like
kind of look at the ecosystem of kind of
the history that's the history
so and Saddam was saying at his like the
last years where like after the first
goal what is his worst and was leading
the country into explosion
um the alternative I think that if the
Iraq war never happened or the US didn't
ever been we would end up exactly like
Syria which is in a weird way now when I
came back to Iraq now there are Sia
refugees who live in Iraq so imagine how
bad Sierra is that they come to Iraq for
for Refugee status so so I went back to
Iraq after 13 years uh and I mostly went
to the Kurdistan region of Iraq even
though I was slightly on the borders of
federal Iraq and mosul and it is really
mind-blowing how the country at least
part of the country has became Iraq
significantly has been stable relatively
over the past couple of years uh the
reasons are kind of somehow Sinister
because but it's also uh a reason I
guess of application of multiple
treatment theories is that now the
political parties of the and the Kurds
have enough investments in the country
so like some of them on shopping malls
and and restaurants and all that stuff
so pretty much all of them now are
interested in keeping the country stable
so now because they have vested
interests they no longer support suicide
bombers and stuff like that so that's
what you don't hear about Iraq on the
news because there has not as far as I
know there has not been a suicide attack
since 2000 like since the defeat of Isis
and as a result the country of resolved
that stability there's now Investments
and people coming in and weirdly but not
weirdly the Kurdistan region asked us so
when I went back to Iraq for For the
First Time 13 years so I met with the
government of Kurdistan at least a
representative of them and they were
like we would love you to open an office
in in ideas we have borders in this
place we are very open to Western ideas
we would like like whatever America has
we actually want some of it we want to
learn about the experiment like
translate more books work with our
universities uh we started like a small
kind of venture funds we called
Innovation Hub uh that supports startups
and things like that so moving towards
privatization so in the in in the grand
scheme of things I think Iraq is doing
much better than I left it which is
itself lost standard but I think is that
it definitely has the potential of
becoming
uh really I mean significantly much
better country even much better than
during Saddam Hussein so and and I think
when people try to
even with I had a debate on slate
magazine which Christopher Hitchens used
to write for for about the Iraq War but
slate went far left after this like
pretty much all the websites and pretty
much all the websites and the thing is
that most of even the conversation was
I mean many of the people who opposed
the War uh and somehow right through
some are bad reasons and but however
most of them may try to connect to
domestic affairs oh Bush sucked we don't
trust Bush and therefore oh we're going
to trust the Republican party and things
like that so eventually I mean many
Americans cannot even name four
provinces in Iraq oh I I think 99 can't
name probably one so so but but at the
same time have very strong opinions
about it so it's definitely a
complicated cell anbar Province how
about that pretty good that's a good one
I mean that's the one where America did
not have a good time but uh but yeah
with that being said it's like I mean
we've seen that also with Afghanistan is
that well and that's I would say is like
one of the reasons why I think people
like me have to take a lead I mean I
don't believe in saviors I think that
people from the region have to fix their
own region and which is a static
organization is the reason why I started
support my organizations in Iraq and
stuff like that in fact my goal of my
organization is ceasing to exist yeah
like we don't we don't want to be we
don't want to build this bureaucracy in
which you just want to advocate for the
cause and you keep raising money just
because uh you there's an organization
you want to maintain So eventually I
think the people there have to I think
America with all its mistakes allowed
the room for that to happen there's now
free Price or free Love Speech but I
know it's under attack even here
that I think is like the seed of
building a functional Society it's a
seed of innovation it's the seed of
progress
um and not progress towards Hell in a
way that progressives in America are but
like but actual progress and I think
that America built that City even in
Afghanistan now we're working with like
underground schools like we built a
network of schools of teachers who
educate girls underground from different
houses all over the place and actually I
was like why the hell you do what you do
like what's really the motivation and
they're like we are the first women to
ever been to school in most of our tribe
and most of the reason why we went to
school is because America came to our
country so in that kind of 20 years
right some of these women went to school
they went to college Etc and now they
feel it's their duty to make sure that
the girls of tomorrow don't end up being
illiterate so that is a success story of
the American intervention the American
withdrawals however that's another story
but I think is that I think that we we
can always talk about the negatives of
the intervention but I but I am seeing
like even when I would love to take you
to Kurdistan
is that you will see that people are
appreciative and I think what what
happens with the Kurds that they took
leadership America did what it can but
then at the same time they're like we
want our country our place to be
developed and they took leadership and
they made it happen so so in effect they
have a it's not I know it's not
technically a country by International
standards but they have a country in
essence right to some extent I mean it's
I mean it's a semi-autonomy not
according to Turkey and not to Iraq I
guess but the politics I mean I mean
that needs like six bottles of tequila
there's just uh but to make it to make
it very very uh simple is that I mean
there are multiple I know that's not the
official narrative but there are
different types of kurts so that's also
part of it I mean even the Kurds
themselves speak different languages
generally speaking the Kurds of Iraq and
Iran speak a similar language I have a
similar Heritage and the ones in turkey
and Syria have a different Heritage
different language the ones in Turkey in
particular who are supported a lot by
the Soviet Union so there's a major
group called The pkk which is mostly
Communists like nut jobs in my opinion
and who have extreme differences with
the ones in Iraq and and Iran
um so there are a lot of kind of issues
within Unity for for the Kurds however
the Kurdistan region of Iraq is kind of
the most successful it's
institutionalized they have their own
parliaments
um and it's definitely a success story
which I think many other occurs from the
neighboring places can look up to as as
a model that they can follow and so if
you are an Arab Iraqi you definitely
need a residency when you enter the
Kurdistan region of Iraq so kind of it's
not a Visa but but you need uh if you
are an iraqi-american then there's like
you can even if you're Arab you can stay
all over you want but so it is
technically I mean the Kurdistan region
of Iraq it's technically as I mean you
see more flags of Kurdistan the other
than if you see flags of Iraq and and
however there are many Arabs and there
are many investors from the Gulf States
and others building fancy hotels and
rest and restaurants and it's it's so
the Kurds they are found out that it's
good to do business with the Arabs and
and not be in that constant state of
tomorrow so in some ways it's you sort
of hinted that this earlier you
basically said it I mean capitalism the
ability to just trade with each other
sort of is the first nugget to getting
to everything else that people suddenly
realize oh I've got to shop I've got
employees there's people around me like
let there's something worth protecting
100 I'm 100 a believer in in the in the
kind of the how connectedness I mean
even now with Saudi Arabia I mean yes we
can talk about a lot about MBS but if
you look at it from the core like Saudi
Arabia because of the fact oil they want
to diversify from oil before they have
oil they can say whatever they want like
it's our oil they don't like us go to
hell now they are they want to open up
for Investments to open up for
Investments you need liberalize and you
need to be open to to capitalism and the
fact that when you're going to bring in
people from Florida and L.A and
everywhere they would like to have a to
bring their girlfriend or their wife or
they would like to bring their the
husband so so as a result they have to
so like in a way the economic freedom or
the incentive to create Investments is
opening up Saudi Arabia which which is
the most conservative place in in the in
the region so I think is that
um I'm that's why I'm running this
dollar even it's actually either pencil
that's the uh which is which talks about
how like the pencil itself is made from
different elements and it needed the
work of multiple people from different
countries to work together to make the
pencil and and that's I think is is
essential piece if we want to move the
region and that's a great thing about
investments in capitalism it reduces
dependency
most of these regions and because of
this shitty International development
organizations like the UN and all of
that what they do is that they create
dependency they they give or the heroes
yes it is here's some food here's some
stuff but then they'll they create a
system in which you have to constantly
give money to the U.N for people not to
start it's just incredible because it's
what we have with all of our welfare
state and then we've exported it into
these giant globalist organizations with
with in some cases bad ideas I mean I I
think the the story yeah in Iraq but
they built a school for like people who
identify as girls or something like that
and people interact
and people have no idea how to translate
that in the first place so there is also
a backlash now a significant backlash I
would say against some of the ideologies
that come with this International
development organizations that they they
kind of give you the give you a bag of
food but it also comes with the whole
baggage of but you have to dress your
son up like a woman yes that I mean that
will go far away in about a province
yeah
um so there is definitely a backlash and
and we try to I mean as an organization
that's new and we try to work we have
our ideals but we try to work within the
region itself
um and even now in the conversation it's
very difficult like to tell people to
westernize but even if you tell them to
westernize what what version of the West
they should westernize to so so the
thing is that the main thing is is to
get people into these ideals and let
them make up and I don't think like the
ultimate goal of Freedom when people get
to know about Classical liberalism they
end up subscribing to the walk telling
Audiology I think is that they become
self-evident and they were like we want
to keep that so that's actually a great
segue to where I wanted to go next which
is that when I first met you there was
there was a really huge uh sort of
secular humanist movement in other good
old days you and I went to the reason
rally in DC together and I spoke at the
National Mall and this is with the sort
of height of Sam Harris and and you
mentioned uh Hitchens before and Dawkins
and there was this feeling of like you
could Escape you could Escape all of the
old of religion and create this sort of
perfect secular thing uh except it's
pretty much falling apart and I and I
suspect that most of your support these
days is somewhat connected to people of
faith more than purely secular
organizations is that is that fair
um both I mean I I would say over most
of our supports comes up from the
classical liberal World
um that would be like Atlas Network and
kind of the and people who support like
the libertarian classical liberal space
I would say very little of our support
comes from that humanist World in fact
that secondary humanist World generally
teared against us is that right they
were like oh you're trying to surprise
the ideas of capitalism that led to
slavery and like that right so the
people that you thought were your great
that's that's what I'm saying yeah
people that you thought were your
greatest allies probably when you got
here and me as a liberal back then yeah
yeah they were the ones that ended up
turning on us the most and they were
supporting in fact the groups that were
going against us so so because of
cultural relativism that's that's was
one of them I would say the conceptual
tenets of of these groups that were
associated with is that they were they
hated their values that made this
country prosperous so in a ways that
they most of the of their criticism is
of America than than other cultures so
in the moment you say oh there is issues
happening in the Muslim world or in the
Middle East and things like that they
always try to drive it back but do you
know America is racist and do you know
that that like you were usually thinking
about that in uh in Iraq yes 97. come on
um exactly it's like it's like when I
was yeah when I was in 97 I was like oh
maybe I should stay in Iraq why
would I get moved to New York right uh
and so so that is generally the the
these kind of groups I think that
the I mean there are secular groups even
within like the iron Crown the
objectivists that were not originally so
like the the secular world is kind of
divided it's between those who mostly on
the left unfortunately uh and there are
those who like kind of the objectivist
and
um and they're out of the Clash and
that's why you don't see them being
invited to these largely kind of
humanist places and
um I think that it's generally terrible
for
because I see a separation between the
importance of separating religion from
the state which is because I've been in
the victim When Death didn't happen in
which the sunnis of their own version
want to make it the case and the shias
want to make the case Etc
um I think that the kind of these these
values can be separated from Concepts
like the welfare state and in America
unfortunately sometimes many of these
things comes as a as a package it's like
you in order for you to believe in
capitalism you also some cases you have
to have a stance on abortion and have a
stance on gun these things are all
connected because you know like the the
the embryos have guns and then so so
like everything has to be connected I I
say that like
even within the founding fathers of the
United States when like part of the
reason why America was established as a
secular nation was they were afraid of
different factions of Christianity it
would actually take over and then then
there would be no the Jews are not
allowed and the Irish Catholics are not
allowed and so so these Concepts
unfortunately like they were champions
for the wrong reasons by a lot of people
within kind of the there's a socialist
and stuff like that who who wanted to in
order for them to sell the package they
were like okay you have to be a
socialist and and join and join us right
um and then when I was telling them
within this crowd that I actually think
that socialism is then they
were like saying me that no you're not a
true humanist and you're not you're a
sellout I'm not brown anymore and yeah
yeah I became uh Betty White yeah um so
so so the thing is that the they wanted
very like I think they have utilized
secularism in a way and like that these
ideas to sell their own bad ideas
because I believe that that can be a
separation I think that even the values
that I advocate for whether in Iraq or
America is mostly coexistence I mean the
thing is that I'm interested so
capitalism we know for centuries has
been a very driving force of getting
people to work together when you connect
countries that leads to more coexistence
when you remove the the one version of
religion to kind of dictate how other
people live that leads to coexistence
and some I am well the Socialists don't
want coexistence they were such as one
dominance
um so I think that unfortunately many of
these things get mixed up in America in
particular like you can go to places
like Norway or Sweden where these things
are a bit separated like there's there's
kind of a history of secularism outside
the Socialist forces and they don't like
you can meet a liberal party in Sweden
right and they're very confident being
secular but also support free markets
there's no they don't see any
contradiction in this but but here even
in England if you say you're a liberal
it has a different kind of exactly and
saying that's why I can't say it in
America anymore with with a degree of
like of confidence well I just have to
then explain it for an hour every time
yeah because I mean um they hijack these
terms
um and I think now it's becoming so
clear we can see these divisions between
kind of the older Democrats the kind of
a neon graduation Democrats in which
those those like from the older side who
kind of followed what they thought was
liberal look at these guys and like you
guys are crazy so there's so there's
divisions here as well in in terms of
kind of liberalism but I think
um I mean to kind of if I see the segue
of your question is that
that the kind of the secular atheist
World led us to what we have right now
and now Peter bagozian is now having
questions about that because he was
unlike me who was like he was an
advocate for atheism as like front and
center he wrote a book called Emanuel
for creating atheists and now most of
his friends are are usually well
certainly people of Faith but mostly
Evangelical Christians I think yeah so
so he's kind of he quit start
questioning uh whether that would be the
kind of the outcome about what they
forget I think there's some truth to
that I think is that we just we we aim
to destroy religion but we had no
alternative idea we just know what we
hated but we know what we stand what we
stood for and and if you look at even
reason rally in many of these places I
mean now I look at it in hindsight there
were places of kind of hate and
resentment they were like we hate the
Christian right we hate this we hate
that but if you ask them about like what
did they actually stood for
it was very blurry uh what I think is
that but if you think about it now many
of us who were there you Michael Shermer
me Melissa Peter bagoge and all that
stuff who used to be kind of critical of
of the religious right all of us moved
to become critical of of the work left
and I think it's that it's no surprise
that is the case because we actually
understood what liberalism is and what
we what we stood for and I think is that
it's it should be more people should be
more outspoken than what we have right
now let's finish with this as a proud
new American and you love your American
jackets and your American shirts and
your American hats and all of those
things when you see the type of
political fighting we have now which we
don't have the sectarian sort of house
to house we're gonna kill you fighting
we certainly don't have that yet but
we've had our riots we have our cities
burning down at times or all of that
stuff which always feels to me like it
could just be turned on at any given
moment you know there could just be some
incident any day today that turns it on
tomorrow
how worried are you that where the way
we deal with politics or the cultural
issues could lead us to basically being
this sort of sectarian you know we're a
huge country but but basically being
this very odd sectarian cannibalized
blob
um I'm worried and not at the same time
I mean I not to quote Bill Clinton but
but I mean he said like I think if I'm
quoting him is that the the the worst of
America can be solved by the best of
America some I over I mean now I've been
to 42 States that's why and I've talked
to many people from different people of
political Isle when I became a US
citizen there were people who support
Trump That Couldn't graduate me there
are people who support uh Hillary that
to support the Democratic party so I
think is that
I mean America is a wonderful country I
think most people
cognitively are not going to really
understand that and believe that I mean
many people when they're like are moving
this country to move to Canada like are
you kidding me you're not moving
to Canada nobody knows you live in
Jersey City and you enjoy your life
there like don't tell me you're moving
to to Canada so so I think many people
when you take it when they are pressured
I think they understood that this
country is great however there is kind
of a sense of virtual signaling of
cynicism and stuff like that to give a
sense I think that's what the world kind
of give to some extent they give a sense
of moral superiority so everybody wants
to have that feeling instead of like
winning a big cross walking in the
streets of Beirut during the Civil War
it gives you like a sense of so I think
that so that's my kind of optimistic
side my least my kind of worried side is
that we have seen this before is that I
mean I would say at least within the
political Arena we have reached a level
I mean even encountered terrorism
circles it's called the level of
dehumanization so it's like you look at
the other side as kind of the enemy and
that deserves to be destroyed
that itself
is like a seed of the worst things can
happen you can do almost because that's
like I mean what we see in the Middle
East and even Balkan places stuff like
that that is like when people reach the
humanization level and then the rule of
flaw gets destroyed and then people
start killing each other
so I think is that America at least in
the political Arena or what is observed
and the thing is that in America
everything can become like an industry
of sorts so like there is an industry of
polarization that that wants people to
uh destroy each other and then claim
that they are the Savior I'm saving it
from the other side I mean when I grew
up in Iraq I mean when people understand
like how did Al-Qaeda and Isis spread in
these places right Isis took over the at
one third of the Iraq in like a couple
weeks and the message of Isis at the
time how they recruited people was not
that oh we're here to destroy the
Christian West it was I am here to
defend you from the other side
and then so all of these kind of
extremists rise in the ecosystem that
allows them to be viewed as the saviors
and I think America is not there yet but
I think there are definitely seeds uh to
to for that to happen and I'm you're
doing your best and I will do my best to
make sure that's this doesn't happen
whether it's through modernization ideas
individually
or through margaritas with margaritas
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell